Welcome back everyone this is going to be my flash season
seven finale video a lot of you requested.
I do a video for the finale just in general.
Even though have been doing videos for all
the episodes will break it all down and I'll
explain what's going on with this and what
they said about season eight so far. Yes,
it does look like they went full star wars
phantom menace with the finale. So I will
explain what's going on. If you're brand-new
to the channel, be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I will be doing videos for
the flash movie separately to because her
in the middle of filming that right now with
Michael Keaton's Batman cannot wait to see
what they do with that obviously careful for
spoilers from everything that happened on
the flash so far if you have not been watching
the episodes this season. The big thing here
is that they're just closing down there God
complex storyline the true version of Godspeed
is setting up what's gonna be happening at
the beginning of season eight the way they
explained Godspeed the real version of Godspeed
on the show is that he was basically someone
in the future who is sending back a bunch
of copies bunch of robots bunch of clones
the past to try and steal speed to give him
speed because he was an artificial speedster
he couldn't use the speed force naturally.
That was one of the big things they change
during this finale. There was a whole storyline
after crisis on infinite earths where Barry
basically had to create a new speed force
because he killed the last one using Oliver's
green spectre cosmic energy from crisis on
infinite earths. So the whole storyline with
him creating the new version of the speed
force the flash forces was meant to set up
the Godspeed storyline the flash winds up
fixing the speed force, eventually giving
birth to this new speed force wormhole alien
that looks like his mother they call her's
before Sonora she somehow has all the memories
of this before Sonora from before, but now
she's able to walk around on earth and actually
interact with the other characters in a way
that she didn't before she's kind of like
an additional speedster on the show but she
is that the physical representation of the
entire speed force they did do some of the
flash forces from the comics, they didn't
do all the forces but by the time they fix
everything. The flash finds out that there's
a Godspeed Civil War happening in all the
copies that Godspeed was sending back into
the past decide to ban together and fight
each other for supremacy. Eventually we find
out about Bart in the future, so obviously
this is after crisis on infinite earths. They
rebooted the entire multiverse. The timelines
different and there is now speed force in
the future. Whereas there wasn't before in
that it been the reason why Godspeed had been
an artificial speedster up to this point.
They explained that in the future. Godspeed
becomes Bart Allen's greatest nemesis. He
winds up killing Jay Garrick in front of him.
They have all this drama together they made
a couple big changes to Bart's character from
the comics. He's very son now. And that's
their way of doing various twins from the
comics, they also explained that this version
of Nora his daughter is not the same one that
died a couple seasons ago. She's like the
brand-new timeline version, so she doesn't
have all the memories of the northern came
before, but Barry basically got her up to
speed and told her what happened with the
previous version of Nora so Godspeed while
he's busy fighting Bart Allen in the future
eventually breaks into the flash Museum uses
the cosmic treadmill to travel back in time
to present day and basically steel true speed
force from Barry so that he does that to be
an artificial speedster anymore also because
of Barry fixing the new speed force Jay Garrick
gets his speed back to so that's how he's
able to help them out. So during the finale.
Godspeed, winds up getting then dead to rights
and agrees not to kill anyone is long as Barry
just gives him true speed force which he does
so Barry essentially creates a version of
comic book Godspeed in the finale, particularly
he turns all them immediately and just is
about to kill Barry reverse flash shows up
with the help of speed force Nora as you can
see they team up and it turns into a full-blown
star wars phantom menace Obi wan and quite
gone, Jen versus Darth Maul lightsaber fight
with speed force lightsabers, which are apparently
thing now they can just do that now reverse
flash trashes Godspeed and then tries to turn
on Barry who manages to fight him off. But
then he went of running off vowing to return
to finish the job in the way Tom Cavanaugh
talks about it. Even though he's not on the
show anymore. He said that he would come back
every once a while and for whatever the final
season, winds up being to have it out one
last time with the flash as reverse flash,
but he also could come back is timeless wells
other version of Wells so is not gone from
the show completely Cisco also left the show
to a little while ago, but he'll come back
for one often cameos every once in a while
their calling him techno five now because
he lost his regular powers. So he's using
technology to give him abilities after their
fight here, they through Godspeed in the meta-wing
of iron Heights, but he still has all of his
natural speed force powers. Now, so he still
a threat in the future we'll see what they
do with them at the beginning of season eight.
I know that a lot of questions about how reverse
flash came back, because the last time we
saw him. He didn't really have a body he only
existed as pure negative speed force energy
with the way they explain it in the finale.
The reason why he's able to manifest in this
body is because of was before Sonora did to
help him come back from the negative speed
force civil wasn't clear he just back now
like he's not pure energy anymore. He doesn't
have the same problem that he had last season,
he's not gonna be the main villain at the
beginning of season eight they said they have
a brand-new villain that's never been in the
Arrowverse before the going to do. They didn't
say specifically who is going to be but they
still have me note that they haven't done
from the comics, they tease her at the beginning
of the season and then we never saw her. So
I just assumed that they were saving her for
season eight there's a couple of other bigger,
newer flash villains from the more recent
comics that they could always introduce in
the showrunner said that he would like to
eventually bring zoom back at some point Hunter
Zolomon. So we'll see about that. My assumption
also is that Bart will continue to be a bigger
character on the show. Nora will also probably
come back a little bit to but it sounds like
just because they introduce the Bart character
recently will see more of him in the early
parts of season eight. The whole thing with
season eight episodes though is they're not
gonna start till November this year. Just
because of the schedule there on in all the
delays that happened last year. So the pie
be about 18 episodes the same number that
they had for season seven. They didn't say
whether or not they plan on it being the last
season, but Grant Guston's contract is up.
So unless he renews beyond season eight. That's
it depends on how big the bags of money they
throw at them are going to be Stephen amell
was very frank when they talked about the
dump truck of money that they offered him
to come back for arrow season eight because
of what was happening during crisis on infinite
earths that year. It was a a lot of money,
but like I said the flash movie is also filming
right now, obviously completely separate.
I think we all expect Grant Gustin to at least
have some source small cameo scene. They haven't
really confirm that but I think the schedule
wind up working out so that they'll be possible.
I will do separate videos about the flash
movie. When we start getting trailers for
that they should be a trailer later this year
at the new DC fandom event also probably get
a new Batman trailer for Matt Reeves Batman
movie, then to give any other big questions
that I didn't really answer during this video
I know I didn't do videos for the season,
but I'm not really watching the show week
to week. I do dip in every once in a while
just to keep track of like a really big stuff
that they're doing. I will be doing episode
videos for the john cena peacemaker suicide
squad TV show but that's gonna be on HBO Max.
It'll be a completely separate thing all explained
that when I start doing more suicide squad
movie videos DC sort of shifting their priorities
in doing more of the marvel Disney plus thing
with the big budget shows. But on HBO Max
like, there's a Batman HBO series is can be
a spinoff from the Robert pattinson movie
they'll be on HBO Max sourcing all that stuff
next year and that will probably be where
I do most of my DC videos outside of the big
DC movies what you wafer everything everyone
click here for that Loki, alternate ending
in deleted scenes video and click here for
that brand-new Loki season two featurette
with Kang. Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you guys tonight!